je suis assez médiocre il ya
actuellement en france une vague de
contestations prêtre le projet de loi
sur l'interdiction de photographier
filmer ou identifier d'une façon ou
d'une autre les agents des forces de
l'ordre
cela se produisait en russie ou en
république de biélorussie
je peux imaginer le bruit que cela
ferait les parisiens les français et les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme s'en préoccupe
mais on ne voit finalement aucune
réaction de la part des organisations
internationales
on utilise des canons à eau et des
grenades assourdissantes lors des
manifestations contre ce projet de loi
les manifestants eux mêmes sont
également livrés à des actes
provocateurs contre la police en se
servant des pierres et des bâtons
un policier a été blessé il ya eu des
reportages à ce sujet le partage